[Musique]
votre lettre est arrivée
une aventure passionnante est sur le point de commencer
[Musique]
les choix que vous avez faits définiront votre
histoire de Poudlard quel genre de sorcière ou de
sorcier serez-vous choisissez votre maison et
apprenez de vos professeurs préférés
[Musique]
crée des amitiés durables
[Musique] en
tant que puissants sorts et potions
[Musique]
découvrez de nouveaux mystères magiques
[Musique
] c'est votre histoire de Poudlard
[Musique]
pré-enregistrez-vous aujourd'hui pour Harry Potter
Poudlard mystère le tout nouveau
jeu mobile Harry Potter
[Musique]
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]